(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] This is
Lilly, an African penguin.
She's a jackass.
No, really.
African penguins are commonly
known as jackass penguins.
Their nickname comes from the
donkey-like sounds they make.
But they're no donkey.
These little guys grow up to
only a little over two feet
and weigh up to eight pounds.
They're only found on the
southwestern coast of Africa,
where they're a popular
sight for tourists.
However, experts say that
if their population decline
isn't stopped, they'll
be extinct in 15 years
You see, African penguins
are pursuit divers
and feed mostly on fish and squid.
But because of competition
from commercial fishing,
they have to go further and
further to find enough to eat.
That, combined with
encroaching human development,
poaching for eggs and oil spills,
are all taking a toll on its population.
This is the African penguin.
(upbeat music)